what's going on there reject nation greg
here today i want to talk about the
flash movie specifically regarding the
ben affleck batman character and what
his fate might ultimately be before we
go into this if you guys go ahead hit
that like button i'd very much
appreciate it i want to say right up
front that no this is not some video
where i'm here to complain about warner
brothers and what they're doing to the
snyder verse or anything like that in
fact i'd say that i'm here to try to
present a more hopeful optimistic
outcome for what might happen in this
movie so with the rumors circulating
around the flash that the snyder verse
will be erased and with words that ben
affleck himself recently had to say
about playing batman in the flash it's
led many to speculate that ben affleck
might actually die in this movie now
like many of you i'm a i'm a firm
believer and restored to the snyder
verse now i know a common thing for
snyder vs fans to react to upon hearing
something like ben affleck might die in
the flashes
hello what are you doing which is a
feeling i completely respect and
initially how i kind of responded
however after diving back into the
comics a bit more hearing what ben
affleck had to say about the role i do
have theories as to how if he does die
how that could actually be a very
powerful and profound moment in the film
that could actually honor what he did
under zack snyder's direction allowing
to leave a lasting impact meaning the
snyder verse isn't entirely erased so
let's just start off with some quotes
about what ben affleck said and how if
he ultimately did die how i think he
would pass on recently he said i've
never said this this is hot off the
presses but my favorite scenes in terms
of batman and the interpretation of
batman that i have done were in the
flash movie i hope they maintained the
integrity of what we did because i
thought it was great and really
interesting different but not in a way
that is incongruent with the character
who knows maybe they will decide that it
doesn't work but when i went and did it
it was really fun and really really
satisfying and encouraging and i thought
wow i think i finally have figured it
out he went on to say that it put a
really nice finish on his experience
with that character i mean that sounds
like a man who's probably gonna die in
this movie like the ultimate hero
sacrifice and i've said this before it
seems like ben affleck is really done
with franchises and is is ready to say
goodbye to blockbusters of of this level
so that way he could focus more on
things that he truly feels passionate
about and it truly makes him happy which
i completely respect but before diving
into how i think he might die or if he
does die i do want to address something
that i've heard be a concern online it
was reported that he only spent about a
week filming for the flash movie which
does sound like an obnoxiously short
amount of time but very recent we
learned that the other two spider-men in
spider-man no way home
spoiler alert they only shot for two
weeks and they had very impactful
substantial screen time in that epic
film so if ben affleck has even half the
amount of time that two other spider-man
had it stands to reason his performance
could leave an impact now one common
speculation that i've heard going around
is that ben affleck will die early on in
this movie and that's why flash
ultimately enters the speed force they
try to rewrite time but he ultimately
hops into another dimension to try and
fix things and he winds up with michael
keaton's batman ultimately through
barry's meddling he makes things worse
before things get better by the end
hopefully now i personally don't
subscribe to this theory that if he does
die that he's gonna die like at the
beginning of this for it to be the
catalyst for the flash movie plot if
anything i think this movie will be
bookended by ben affleck's batman now
here's what i think might happen real
quick in case you guys forgot part of
barry allen's backstory his father went
to prison because he was wrongfully
accused of murdering his mother when he
was just a little wee boy and one thing
that barry allen desires to do is go
back in time and prevent the death of
his mother so when starting off this
movie when setting up at what point in
time barry is at in his life i believe
he'll have maintained a relationship
with ben affleck's batman and through
conversing with batman that's where
he'll get the idea to time travel from
either one of two things a
they actually maintain zack snyder's
justice league where you know he's
reflecting on i did actually time travel
a little bit and i did a pretty good job
doing that or b which sounds like a more
likely scenario to me ben affleck will
tell him about the dream sequence that
he had in bvs where he will tell him
that what helped save the world would
help unite the league was barry allen
time traveling back and saying lois is
the key i think a light bulb will go off
and barry allen's had to go back in time
to try to save his mom from being killed
but instead of time traveling back in
time like in the flashpoint comic he'll
actually time travel to another universe
the earth 89 universe i believe is what
it's called as established from crisis
on infinite earths which edison miller
did appear in now if there's anything we
can learn from unguarded multiverse
traveling in any work of fiction is it
creates a cacophony of problems ruptures
in time or the universe often resulting
in the possibility of a particular
universe ending so i think by the end of
this movie that in order for barry allen
to save the day both universes will be
in jeopardy and you'll need to somehow
combine the universes preserving some of
the ongoing snyder verse hence why we're
getting like an aquaman two a wonder
woman three commissioner gordon's will
still be alive and batgirl but having to
erase or replace some i believe the
final decision to save the universe
comes from a decision influenced by ben
affleck's batman that instead of saving
the batman in the timeline barry knows
he'll ultimately save the one from the
keaton universe so the question is why
the answer comes down to one man
robin see in the flashpoint comic which
this movie is obviously very much
inspired from barry allen time travels
back in time to prevent the death of his
mother but upon doing so creates an
alternate timeline where bruce wayne is
actually the one who dies in the alley
and thomas wayne ends up becoming the
batman and i think the role that ben
affleck will ultimately play in this
movie will be more reflective of the
role that thomas wayne served in the
comic i mean hell even if you're looking
like bvs bruce is already a lot more
like thomas wayne he's a man with a near
death wish he's willing to kill and he's
scorned by the loss of his son who died
at the hands of a criminal and then zack
snyder confirmed that the suit that we
saw in batman v superman the one that a
lot of us thought was jason todd suit
was actually dick grayson's suit meaning
in the snyder verse in ben affleck's
timeline robin aka dick grayson is dead
so i think what this movie will show us
maybe through like alluding to or a
direct conversation at the beginning of
this film is that the relationship that
ben affleck has formed with barry allen
is helping to fill a void after the loss
of dick grayson so robin no longer
exists in the timelines universe however
set photos of batgirl a movie in which
michael keaton is set to return confirms
that robin does indeed exist and is
alive within the keaton universe so in
the flashpoint comic when it comes to
restoring the timeline to what it once
was thomas wayne encourages barry allen
to restore the timeline in spite of the
fact knowing that if barry allen does
this thomas will be the one who
ultimately dies in the alley but thomas
doesn't care why because bruce wayne
gets to live on his son gets to live on
and i think ben affleck's bruce wayne
will do exactly this or at least his
decision will be influenced by this
damage will be done to earth 89 and the
flash will be left with a choice on how
to save the universes ben affleck's
batman will make the decision for barry
because at least in the universe of
keaton dick grayson still gets to live
now honestly i have no idea if any of i
don't even know if robin's even gonna be
in this movie i haven't heard any
reports about robin being in here i've
heard some reports about casting of
robin being in batgirl but to me you
know if if they do something like this
where ultimately it is a hero's
sacrifice for him i think that would
make ben affleck's character actually
come full circle and really honor him at
the setup of bvs at that mournful part
of where ben affleck is at at this point
in his life he's experienced so much
loss and he obviously is still very much
reflective on what really changed him
and it's clear that a lot of that stems
from the fact that dick grayson died you
have that really kind of popular scene
where he is looking at the suit of dick
grayson so if you start him off on this
like a dark point and then eventually he
helps form the justice league creates
heroes and then his final day is being a
hero is sacrificing himself so that way
robin gets to live that just sounds like
a beautiful arc to me that sounds like
something that would actually work in a
good way for him to say goodbye and a
way to actually put a stamp on the
character that still honors who he was
in the snyder verse movies now i know
one thing people have been talking about
recently is this cryptic post ezra
miller put out it's a screenshot of ben
affleck's batman talking about how he'd
be playing him one last time in it ezra
underlined the words one last time and
scribbled the words haha all over it in
joker like font many took this as an
indicator that this will not be the last
time ben will be playing him another way
to interpret it would be that ben can
continue playing him if discovery
decides to move forward with the zack
snyder justice league sequels maybe the
haha is also reflective of what we've
been talking about in this video though
ha ha writing similar to how they were
on robin's suit in bvs the moment in
time for ben affleck's batman that will
serve as the driving force of his
character's sacrifice in the flash
i don't know maybe i'm just saying
things to support my argument but that's
just my opinion and that's just my
theory so i don't know if maybe ben
affleck does die at the beginning or
maybe he doesn't die he just gets erased
i have no idea but if something like
this were to play out i think this would
be great and i feel like there's some
evidence that at least points to this
all right guys but what do you think
about my theory what's your theory on
what might happen with ben affleck leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
the notification bell hit that like
button and i'll catch you soon